a Texas woman has been charged with murder for
what authorities are calling a self-induced
abortion. This is sadly completely predictable
based on what Texas has been doing as far as
abortion law. For years now and really for decades
now in terms of what they've been trying to do
and one of the lines that's repeated so often
that it's like cliche, we've all heard it so
many times. It's a cliche at this point is
banning abortion doesn't reduce abortions,
it just reduces legal abortions in your particular
state. What does that mean? Well, it means
if you make abortion more difficult
to obtain or you make it illegal,
you make it illegal. In more situations, people
will either go to a neighboring state if they
can afford it and if it's legal in a neighboring
state or they will pay for an illegal abortion.
This is very common in other countries. I
mean, if you if you look at where I was born
Argentina, there were long periods of time
where it was illegal. But if you had money,
you just went to a private doctor and it was fine
and you had the money to do it. That's the second
option. Third option what we sometimes call a back
alley abortion, a home abortion. In this case,
it's being called a self-induced abortion.
And that is exactly what happened here,
with 26 year 26 year old Lizelle Herrera,
who was arrested less late last week and
has been charged with murder. Herrera was given
a five hundred thousand dollar bond. Five half
a million dollars we are talking about here.
Now remember that this idea of, I don't know,
do we punish the women? This is something
Republicans have been toying with for
a long time. They've tended to go against it. But
remember that when Donald Trump ran Trump, who
Trump is pro-choice, Trump was pro-choice for 68
years. Then he ran for president as a Republican,
and he had to have some kind of credible escape
hatch to explain. Suddenly, I'm against abortion.
He's speaking at the March for Life. The story
Trump told us completely unbelievable story
was that despite being in favor of choice
for 68 years, he met a kid whose mom said,
I thought about getting an abortion,
and Trump was like, I like that kid.
It would have been sad if that kid didn't exist.
So now I'm the strongest pro-life camp. I mean,
it was nobody believed it. And a result of
Trump not actually being pro-life was that
he stepped into some controversial territory,
like when he said, Well, you've got to punish the
woman. Remember this?
Do you believe in punishment for abortion?
Yes or no? Is a principle. The answer is
that it has to be some form of punishment
for the woman. Yeah, it has to be some form,
potentially 10 years ago that I don't.
Right. So the next day, Trump walked it back. But
the punishment for back alley or home abortions
that they seem fine with and we have other
instances of similar situations you might
remember back in October, just a few months ago,
six or seven months ago? Yeah, seven months ago,
we covered the story, I think, on the bonus show
of a Native American woman in Oklahoma who was
convicted of manslaughter over a miscarriage.
This was Brittany Poole, 21 years old,
convicted on second degree manslaughter by a
Comanche County jury for the death of her fetus
with the gestational age of 15 to 17 weeks.
So don't be confused about the big picture
of how Texas has dealt with abortion. The
number of abortion clinics in Texas has declined
dramatically. You go back to the mid-1980s and
we're putting a chart up on the screen for our
viewers. Over 120 clinics at which abortion
services were available, that is now
under 20 as of a few years ago. It may be even
lower now. I didn't have updated data. So people
really may have no idea what we're in for here.
If Republicans get their way and this is really
about two things. It's actually it's really
about three things. Number one, this is about
on paper, reducing the number of abortions in
Texas. Now, remember, you're not actually reducing
the number of abortions. You might reduce the
number of legal abortions in Texas because people
will either be pushed to other states if they can
afford it, or they will be pushed into, you know,
so-called private back alley home abortions.
That's number one. Number two, this continues
to be about controlling women's bodies in a
way that lines up with the stated morals of the
people doing it. And it's important to include
the way the word stated morals. Because,
as we have found out through the election of Trump
with evangelical support, despite his affairs and
all of these, we know that they are only their
stated morals. It's not their morals, their their
morals that they use to try to get themselves
elected. And then number three, it's also a real
sign about what might be coming at the Supreme
Court level within months. The Supreme Court, one
of the most right wing Supreme Courts we've had
in decades, is going to make a decision that might
change the established precedent of Roe v. Wade
making abortion legal in the country, generally
speaking, without placing an undue burden on
women. That framework, that precedent may be
reversed in just months by the current Supreme
Court. The states are pushing it because this has
always been the plan when they get a more
conservative Supreme Court. They all start doing
it. Mississippi, Texas, Missouri. Many states
have been pushing and passing similar bills,
knowing that they're going to be fought. They're
going to be appealed. Hopefully, they go to the
Supreme Court and the Supreme Court will issue
what could be a life changing ruling for so many
women and families around the country. Is it
time to move out of Texas? Well, I don't know.
Part of it is a question of
what does the Supreme Court
decide? And we're going to know that soon. But
this is exactly what we predicted they would do.
They are doing it, and you can look at any
one of these cases and say, Well, but in this
particular case or in that particular, this was
the plan all along. We knew that they were going
to do it and they're going to continue.